no she knows no see away
no service okay that is legally
something that businesses can say in the
same way you can have requirements for
coming into business tamar including
gonna be wearing sure you gotta be
in which a shirt for public health
services for sanitation purposes
businesses can  say you carry
vaccinated gents cobit 1915 the start
in other countries and were nothing the
start in the united states
restaurant fast customers innovation no
service and sets the various pride is an
interesting hard case marketwatch
esko business increase
stacks of coins requiring customers the
trial the full box  and food and the dwelling in
the protests and the process not
surprisingly
escober 19 choose thirst u de usa
growing number of guiding and drinking
establishments turning on wax and
food customers or a single business is
cresco public s'posing patrons en
stepped dwyer
de the  snow box no service decisions have
sparred controversy with the en tibet
chinese and groups and in  dividuals and
they constitute a violation of civil
rights
sam becoming options for the in texas
have knocked listening century
prevent private business is
positive ben johnny and touches and ether and
cds bonus show you will talk about
the spy watch republic and trumpy and gave
a round of santas is then in for the
edges am any such boxing requirements
mayor's al over florida in the faire part
of lord of the final round ass blonde
santas
and his nolet more expensive action in the
MP salad wax in requirements
and i will talk about her entrance  bonus
show on the bars and restaurants pudding see
the way requirements instead range
of individual young ones the small
change in san francisco local barony
organization representing more than 300
the piles of coin and us monday
something calling for by customers to show
proof vaccination
or negative copy  testing and there bars
religion started doing this part of
spain to born to be doing with
friends sunshine ranch little  italy
mebius is could takes an action shirley
peter incident not door apartment will
be allowed to it out
that the and local drinking spots ben
blimbing president of the san francisco
barony reliance in a bar proprietor
himself
cells so hard your north often the
code nineteen can  easily be spread by and
vaccinate in the visuals that's
how time under the internet iphone
case is de ben is simple necessary
it seems to be the easiest and fastest to
know perfect people
choose at city winery and national bar and
restaurant no drivers live music at
plans architecture  en maria how is
such a good peeling
simcity winery kicks in new york in a
belief in boston city winery already
have seen reform and place fresh new
york city location after serving
customers to what the country
last files at e-mail is decided  to
extender apartment at all it is devilish
my styling next week more than seven
5% customers to respond to the survey
supporter see the way also wa  rm and who
already said that wi-fi is there is new york
city vanilla my talk to do some and the
for performance
gigi standing ovation on this is could
be the new barrel this is could offer
new barrel and who is leather amro in the
show you is apparently licking too 5 euros
the taxi leather full glozell green anne
compleat center on that masks on the
front of the houses wrappers and groups who
you're going to see her your child engine
of the american population
go absolutely cooper coco pops based on
your iconia
business is not region members the in this
way by the government in hollywood the
government is a glass to go
around with the garmin is na regulating
business is and so representation of you
must
or you can now or whatever put in place
of action  now hot and business there is
deciding fordham even the weaver paul
liekens claim
d what businesses to be able to do hey
arwi better off everywhere we see the way
requirement to come cross devils mentor
took and of people see the wax in her
arms and dc that shareable
sir who present then they can choose not
to go to date en stacks with the business
is able to make a decision they believe
is best for them they may be right a
baby on board
er right to make a decision and then  us
consumer can say hi wake up is
business
with my money home with my dollars
die cause i like the rule of
i'm going to avoid this business you may
choose to avoid a business week as they
go have wax in your arms
you might show  for the business week
as they do not have wax in her arms and
each we
everybody has made a choice dat is best
for them you never right to go on rocks
in ede de tour driver restaurant
i will be up to you to go where you
wanna  go dutch test libertarian small
government
ido ar nu met for what is going on at
isense so also as my government and
services or no-go in the take it to where
i'm feeling around terminus food
violation of the constitution
heat wireless and pipa hip  orange ulf
male  ager at lower right on do come on i
get eating violation ipod pinned by lid
en de disc only be delayed ist 7 not your
name die sig sauer
scandal online media that the
expectation iphone at mondego in the
start cm
speaking of import monday's by the way
who there is no one to a history man this we
of the sixteens anniversary of the day
feedback my show already such is so 16
here windows 10 year anniversary so that
's that herodes an oxymoron right 16 hours
and there is the 16th anniversary denim shirt
blue monday august 16
wiardi in a one day membership special
kings the membership bar bar that the
ball nice in the op in the best since the
not in my hand of an account manager
interested in signing up and in extreme
discount to celebrate this 16 year
anniversary
please sign up for my newsletter idea
that my day comment on monday august
16th will be notified
hey here is how to sign up and take
advantage of the disco